both presidential candidates are trying
to win over key voters in this final
stretch of the campaign
the president was in pennsylvania and
joe biden was in florida
yesterday both working to appeal to
older americans
and to other voters too ben tracy is
following the race for us
at a rally in johnstown pennsylvania
last night president trump tried to make
up lost ground with suburban voters
suburban women would you please like me
remember please please
i saved your damn neighborhood okay and
seniors
who recent polls show back former vice
president joe biden by a wide margin
biden's agenda would be a catastrophe
for seniors
biden cares more about illegal aliens
than he cares about your senior citizens
and it's true
the demographic was crucial to president
trump's win in 2016.
who's better for seniors and while the
trump campaign is scrambling
launching a multi-million dollar ad
blitz to try to win them back
the president tweeted this doctored
image of biden at a senior living
residence
with the words biden for resident the
only senior that donald trump cares
about
the only senior is senior donald trump
in florida tuesday biden laid out his
vision for america's seniors
and called president trump's plan to use
medicare dollars to send out
prescription drug
cash cards in election year gimmick he
thinks that he can take the money
out of your pocket with one hand and put
it back with his name stamped on it on
the other hand
and call it a gift it's dishonest
it's reckless biden's campaign is
relentlessly attacking the president's
response to the virus
he was warned but ignored the evidence
holding rallies indoors
biden said by downplaying it the
president has shown he doesn't care
about the sacrifices vulnerable seniors
have had to make
while he throws super spreader parties
at the white house
where republicans hug each other without
concern of the consequences
how many of you have been unable to hug
your grandkids
in the last seven months now biden is
about to get some high-profile help from
his old boss former president barack
obama aides close to mr obama tell cbs
news he plans to hit the campaign trail
in the coming days
to stump for biden anthony ben thank you